democrats go down to flaming defeat in
virginia minnesota defund the police
implodes and a democratic socialist
loses to a write-in candidate in buffalo
i'm ben schmo this is the bench bureau
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show you sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn.com
ben speaking of which how did you choose
which internet service provider you
wanted to use well the thing is most of
us have very little choice because isps
operate basically like monopolies in the
regions they serve worst of all many
isps log your internet activity and then
sell that data to other big tech
companies or advertisers to prevent isps
from seeing my internet activity i
protect all my devices as you know with
expressivevpn so what is vpn you ask
great question it's a simple app for
your computer or smartphone it encrypts
all your network data it tunnels it
through a secure vpn server so your isp
can't see your activity think about how
much of your life is on the internet
your credit card numbers all your phone
numbers address it like everything you
need is on the internet why would you
just put that data out there for anyone
to grab that's the reason i recommend
expressvpn it's the best way to hide
your online activity from your isp as
well as hackers and anybody else who
wants it you just download the app you
tap one button on your device and you
are now protected expressvpn does all of
that without slowing your connection
which is important to me since i run an
internet-based company so stop handing
over your personal data to isps and
other tech giants who mine your activity
and sell off your information protect
yourself with the vpn i trust to keep me
private online visit
expressvpn.com that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
to get three extra months for free go to
expressvpn.com
right now to learn more okay so
democrats
not great last night not great bob at
all so democrats went down to flaming
ferocious defeat in virginia it was just
a bloodbath a brutal sickening bloodbath
and very upsetting it just did i am so
i'm just all broken up about it now
remember joe biden had predicted massive
victory while he was in glasgow
yesterday it turns out that joe biden
couldn't be woken up to deliver the
actual bad news this morning but here he
was yesterday trying to trying to say
that everything is going to go great in
virginia last night it did not go great
in virginia spoiler alert
we're going to win
i think we're going to win in virginia
and you know you're reporting it being
close the race is very close it's about
who shows up who turns out
and granted i did win by a large margin
but the point of the matter is that i
think that this is this is going to be
we all knew from the beginning this
could be a tight race
okay we didn't all know that from the
beginning if you look at the polls glen
yunken was down like double digits at
the beginning of this race and then he
won last night by a fairly solid margin
according to the new york times
republicans claimed the governorship of
virginia for the first time in more than
a decade on wednesday electing a
businessman glenn yonkin and presenting
their party with a formula for how to
exploit president biden's
vulnerabilities and evade the shadow of
donald trump in democratic-leaning
states youngkin at 54 a wealthy former
private equity executive making his
first run for office elevated education
and taxes while projecting a suburban
dad demeanor to demonstrate he was
different from trump without saying so
outright he defeated former governor
terry mcauliffe a democrat who with
trump out of office struggled to
generate enthusiasm among liberals at a
moment when conservatives are energized
in opposition to mr biden this race was
called pretty much off the bat by fairly
early last night people knew that young
kin was going to win and it wasn't just
that republicans won with jungkoon at
the top of the ticket they also won
lieutenant governor's race in virginia
they won the attorney generals raised in
virginia and in fact
they elected the first black female
lieutenant governor in the history of
the state of virginia
i believe the first hispanic a.g in the
history of the state of virginia which
means as we'll see that the republicans
again demonstrating their vicious brutal
white supremacy in the oddest of ways by
electing a very diverse slate of
candidates to higher office
meanwhile by the way
over in new jersey in new jersey it is a
dead heat right now between the
republican gubernatorial candidate jack
citarelli who no one knew who he was or
knows who he is today against phil
murphy who is the widely touted governor
of new jersey it was captain covet over
there he locked it down pretty much
everything and he was supposed to run
away with that race the polls showed
that he was up by near double digits not
like months ago like mcauliffe was then
the race tightened he was up double
digits pretty much a week ago he was up
eight in the real clear politics polling
average yesterday and now that race is
so deadlocked it's going to go to
recount
according to the new york times no less
bracing for democrats was a second
gubernatorial election unfolding in new
jersey the incumbent governor philip
murphy was narrowly trailing a
relatively obscure republican challenger
jack shittarelli deep into the night a
mainstream liberal with ties to the
white house murphy was staking his hopes
for a comeback on a strong performance
in several solidly democratic areas
where votes were slow to report again
about 98 of the vote in at this point
and it's pretty much dead heat the
unexpected closeness of the race
underscored the overall vulnerability of
the democratic party much like mr young
in virginia mr siatarelli appeared to
benefit from robust turnout in rural and
conservative-leaning areas of the state
while making inroads in denser areas
such as bergen county the populist
suburb of new york city
unlike younkin shadarelli a former state
legislator had no
vast personal fortune to spend on his
candidacy national republicans looked at
his campaign as an extreme long shot
even if murphy were to prevail it's
going to be by
my new fraction remember joe biden won
the state of new jersey by 16 points 16
points joe biden won the state of
virginia by 10 points
brutal brutal so youngkin in virginia he
said today we are going to change the
trajectory of this commonwealth
meanwhile mcauliffe refused to concede
as of late last night instead he just
went out and did like a weird little
dance who's very very strange
bottom line is terrible news in virginia
for the democratic party
and if you look at the internals on the
poll numbers they're just
i mean horrifying for the democrats
loudoun county right that is a
democratic county there is a 19 point
swing to the gop in loudoun county and
here i must give a shout out to the
daily wire zone reporter luke rosiak
who's been doing unbelievable reporting
from on the ground in loudoun county and
he is the person who uncovered this
massive scandal wherein the school board
of loudoun county was essentially
covering up the rape of a student in
their bathroom while promoting a
transgender bathroom bill
and turns out there are all sorts of
other
issues with malfeasance by the school
board in that district
and that county swung 19 percentage
points toward republicans in this
election cycle so investigative
reporting matters you should head on
over to dailywire.com subscribe and use
code real news get 25 off honestly
support our investigative reporting
efforts they really do make a difference
also shout out to christopher ruffo who
did an unbelievable job covering
critical race theory across the country
as well specifically in virginia as we
will see democrats their plan is just to
deny that they are radical at all and
then to call everyone who notices a
racist a 19-point swing in loudoun
county
also
mcauliffe
according to sahil kapoor who's a
national political reporter at nbc news
mcauliffe the democrat he ran a bit
ahead of biden among the non-white
voters in virginia he ran ahead of biden
among those voters he got absolutely
clocked by white women
in 2020 white women went for biden 50 to
49.
it wasn't a bigger margin because a lot
of rural and non-college educated white
women went for trump so it was 50 to 49
for biden in virginia in 2020
virginia 2021
young kin 57
mcauliffe 43 that is a 15 point swing to
the gop with that group that is
particularly among white women who are
non-college graduates
in 2020 56 of white women who are
non-college graduates went for trump 44
went to biden
okay so that was a a split in favor of
trump but
a lot evener than last night last night
75 for yonkin 25 from a call-off among
white women or non-college educated
okay what does that say it says that
when you have someone who is not quite
as offensive at the top of a particular
ticket that you can win back all of
those suburban white women you can hold
the trump coalition which is what young
kin did he didn't crap on trump he
didn't spend the campaign crapping on
trump instead he said he appreciated a
lot of things about trump but he also
didn't humor a lot of trump's more
absurd contentions and then he made the
issues not about trump he just avoided
making the election about trump and he
swamped terry mcauliffe particularly
with white women
we'll get some more of the poll analysis
in just one second because it's really
fascinating and it does spell a way
forward for republicans moving forward
first
got to tell you about the greatest chair
on planet earth i of course i'm talking
about the ex chair i have a question can
your current office chair give you a
massage while you are working my extra
can because it's like a slice of heaven
can your current office chair heat up or
cool down my exterior can it's all in
the lmx massage and temperature
regulation exclusively designed and made
for x-chair once you feel the customized
support of extra's patented dynamic
variable lumbar support or dvl your back
will never be happy in any other chair
ever again high performance quality
engineering extreme comfort those are
the reasons i love my ex chair i can't
wait to sit on that x chair at work it's
that good and when i'm not here my
producers have fist fights in the break
room over who gets to sit in the x chair
take my advice try extra for yourself
risk free for 30 days once you realize
how much better your chair should be you
will never go back i promise head on
over to exchair shapiro.com right now
that is the letter x chair
shapiro.com or call one eight four four
four x chair for a hundred bucks off
your order extra has a 30 day guarantee
of complete comfort you can finance your
purchase for as little as 30 bucks a
month ex chairshapiro.com again that's
exchair
shapiro.com okay back to some of these
exit polling numbers just brutal for the
democrats on the economy and jobs 35
percent of voters in the virginia
election said that was their top issue
the economy and jobs young kin won that
group 63 to 36
okay on the issue of education which was
the number three issue among these exit
voters 15 people said it was their
number one issue
71 percent one for yunkan 71-29
hey that is luke's reporting that is
chris ruffo's reporting that is people
who are pointing out what exactly is
being taught to your kids in schools
that is not a virginia issue by the way
that is a national issue and if
republicans don't hold on to that if
they don't point out i've been saying
this literally since i began my career
the indoctrination of children in public
schools is a disaster area for the
country if republicans run on the
curriculum they're going to win because
parents don't actually know what kids
are being taught okay so on the economy
and jobs junkin outpaces macaulay 63-36
on education he outpaces mccall of 71-29
on coronavirus mcauliffe wins 78-22 but
no one cares about that anymore because
basically this is all over
among people who said racism was their
number one issue unsurprisingly
mcauliffe won 84 to 15. on abortion only
five percent of people said it was their
top issue but 56 of those people
actually voted for yunkan so all of the
anti-choice he's an anti-choice radical
who's going to stop abortion that
actually cut in young king's favor on
immigration ninety-four percent to five
in favor of yonkin and so you can see
exactly why young can won right here
how bad were the exit polls for
democrats here
hey i'm gonna go by by group here okay
so among eighteen to forty four men
young can one uh young kin was
competitive he only lost him a call of
52 to 47
among men aged 45 plus 58 to 42 for
young kin among latinos and hispanics
in virginia youngkin won outright 54 to
45. he also won 13 of the black vote and
of the white vote
devastating numbers for the democrats
plus as nate cohen points out over the
new york times
biden has nearly the worst approval
ratings of any president on record at
this stage of his presidency the worst
approval ratings of any president on
record at this stage of his presidency
okay so a few takeaways right here okay
number one it turns out that telling
your voters to vote is actually a better
strategy than telling your voters not to
vote republicans in those georgia senate
races at the beginning of this year they
basically told their voters your vote
doesn't matter and then people didn't
show up and then republicans lost in
what is a red state
okay virginia is a very blue state and a
republican said you should show up and
you should vote and your vote counts
and whether or not you are concerned
about voter fraud the best way to win is
to go and vote
and focusing in on are they going to
steal it is it going to be stolen is
your voting account is a bad way of
running an election cycle is a bad idea
moving forward okay point number two run
against the democrats as always run
against the democrats make the democrats
your opponent i said this throughout
2020 if people had thought that joe
biden was the issue joe biden would have
lost they didn't they thought trump was
the issue and so trump lost in virginia
people thought terry mcauliffe and the
democrats were the issue so young can
won it's that simple if the election is
about your opponent your opponent loses
teremikov tried to do that to yunkan and
he completely failed because junkin is
inoffensive junkin does not make people
feel uncomfortable
youngkin makes it very youngkin did what
good candidates do he made it very
difficult to vote for his opponent he
made it very easy to vote for him
that is what good candidates do
bad candidates make it easy to vote for
your opponent and difficult to vote for
you that's what a bad candidate does
that's what terry mcauliffe did he went
out there like a fool and he said
parents should not be in control of
their children's education and then he
kept doubling down on that while
campaigning with randy weingarten he
kept telling parents that they are
racist if they mention the phrase
critical race theory he kept saying over
and over and over again that parents
should not determine whether or not they
are indoctrinated their kids are
indoctrinated with lgbtq propaganda in
schools that's up to the school boards
right that is it he made it very
difficult for people to vote for him and
he made it very easy for people to vote
for yonkin because he guessed he he just
kept shouting that junkin was a racist
trumpkin
they kept saying it over and over and it
just didn't wash because junkin isn't
and so young can won
these these are major lessons that
republicans need to take for the future
if they hope to continue winning also
further lessons republicans should not
shy away from the culture wars so i know
that there's the smart set in republican
politics who are constantly saying that
the culture wars are a dummies it's a
dummies game why are you arguing on
culture the answer is culture motivates
people culture gets people up in the
morning
you know how your kids are educated in
schools matters a lot more to people
than their marginal tax rate
i care a hell of a lot about my marginal
tax rate it makes a big difference in my
life but i can tell you how my kids are
educated in school matters one million
times more than that
when republicans abandon the social
issues when they pretend that social
issues don't matter or they are a
distraction from the main issues this is
sort of how romney ran his campaign in
2012. they lose
romney did not run against barack
obama's radicalism in 2012. he ran
against his economic plan that is not
how you win the way that you win is by
pointing out the social radicalism of
your political opponent and presenting a
good economic plan which is what young
kin did
also this race made clear that
republicans can indeed keep together the
trump coalition and they don't have to
have all of the bad tweets to go along
with it
kirsten soltas anderson who's a pollster
for the washington she has a piece for
the washington examiner she points out
junkin got all the upside of trump but
none of the downside
she says there's little doubt trump will
try to take credit for young victory to
be clear trump quite literally phoned it
in at the last minute for young kin
after enough polls showed victory was in
sight young kin and trump did not donate
to each other young king said the bare
minimum about trump necessary to survive
the primary process
what trump did do over the last five
years was engage many formerly
disconnected voters and turn them into
more habitual voters for the gop so that
was good what trump did
he he continues to have an impact on
politics by turning out to vote in rural
areas just by having activated people
who are now used to voting that's a big
thing
young kid's savvy move was not to
embrace trump but also not to insult
trump or disavow him he was not about
being pro or anti-trump he was about not
being trump he was about being young kin
okay and biggest lesson of all right now
republicans have a target rich
environment the democrats are an
absolute mess they're a mess
joe biden is a disaster area and again
it wasn't just in virginia it's all over
the country it's all over the country
and to give you some results from other
areas of the country that really cut
against the democratic party 2022 is
looking like an absolute wipeout for the
democrats
i would not be surprised if republicans
pick up 40 to 50 seats in the house
i certainly would not be surprised in
this environment if democrats lose the
senate outright
we'll get some more on this in just one
second first
if you're a homeowner who's been focused
on your budget focused on your future
focused on finding the right option to
save money that's something for you to
consider a mortgage refinance it's a
strategic approach that makes sense for
a lot of people since rates remain near
all-time lows making an excellent time
to call american financing learn about
custom loan options that can save you up
to a thousand bucks a month that's right
every single month because they do more
than just lower your rate they look at
your entire financial picture they find
every way to help you save no pressure
no obligation no upfront or hidden fees
so why not learn more they'll give you a
free mortgage review and you may skip
two payments if you choose to move
forward pre-qualify for free by calling
866-721-3300 that is
866-721-3300 or visit
americanfinancing.net remember those
mortgage rates are basically at all-time
lows right now they will go up sometime
in the near future so if you're thinking
about a mortgage refi and you're
thinking maybe i'll wait on it don't
wait on it go check out the
possibilities right now at
americanfinancing.net pre-qualify for
free by calling
866-721-3300 that's 866-721-3300
and mls 182 334 and mls consumer access
dot org okay so it wasn't just in
virginia again in new jersey that is a
dead heat in a state that is bluer than
blue
and that state has been blue for a very
long time phil murphy was expected to
walk away with that race he is not
walking away with that race meanwhile
over in pennsylvania the gop as of last
night was poised to sweep all judicial
appellate races
according to penlive.com republican
kevin brobson edged out democrat maria
mclaughlin to win a spot on
pennsylvania's highest court
unofficial election results early
wednesday showed brobson currently a
commonwealth court judge with 53 percent
of the vote with brobson's projected
victory republicans will keep one of
their two seats on the seven member
court there's another election looming
the appellate courts were up for
election and all of them went republican
that's in pennsylvania again which is a
purple state at best
meanwhile
in new jer how bad was new jersey for
the democrats last night new jersey was
so bad last night that the state senate
president okay law
lost apparently to a guy who had a 200
budget
and no campaign
that's how bad it was for democrats last
night i mean for god's sake democrats
got wiped out in long island
okay a red tide swept over long island
according to the new york post with the
republican candidates for district
attorney in both nassau and suffolk
counties winning their races in stunning
landslides on tuesday turning the
campaigns into referenda on new york's
controversial bail reform law in nassau
career local prosecutor anne donnelly
upset democratic state senator todd
kaminsky a former federal prosecutor who
voted for a 2019 law eliminating cash
bail
donnelly who is deputy chief of the
nassau da's organized crime and rackets
bureau won 60 percent to 40 for kaminsky
it's a 20-point blowout
and so nassau and suffolk both go
republican
and it's in new york meanwhile over in
texas republican john lujan won a
special election runoff and flipped a
texas house seat in san antonio
that is a majority hispanic district
and that so again
the look for a lot of democratic
retirements coming up guys this is a bad
bad night for democrats all the way
across the country
meanwhile in minneapolis you remember
that time that defunded the police was
the big thing in minneapolis because of
george floyd and derek chauvin well that
was on the ballot last night and it went
down to flaming defeat
according to the new york times
minneapolis residents rejected an
amendment on tuesday that called for
replacing the city's long tribal police
department
with a new department of public safety
the ballot item emerged from anger after
a minneapolis police officer murdered
george floyd last year galvanizing about
galvanizing residents who saw the
policing system as irredeemably broken
but the amendment's failure showed that
even in a liberal city where skepticism
of the police runs deep many americans
are not prepared to get rid of the cops
so
even in minneapolis people like nope we
are not going to do that
in buffalo new york there's a lot of
talk about this particular mayoral race
there's a lot of talk about this race
because india walton had been nominated
as the actual democratic candidate she
was a socialist she was endorsed by
chuck schumer in aoc
an actual socialist right and chuck
schumer jumped on the bandwagon because
he was afraid that aoc is going to run
against him for the senate in new york
so india walton had the upper hand she
had the party's base of support she just
got destroyed
okay the buffalo mayor's race went to a
guy
who was a democrat was the incumbent but
who was not
on the ballot he was a write-in
candidate
a writing candidate beat the democratic
socialist by almost 20 points in buffalo
byron brown said that people chose four
four more years of a brown
administration the people chose one of
the greatest comeback stories in our
history
meanwhile india walton said i'm
extremely proud of the campaign that
we've run i'm looking forward to seeing
the final results come in i'm looking
forward to working with all of our
current city electeds and all of the
winners tonight
a walton mayoral win would have been a
win for socialism
nope just blown blown out in in buffalo
in in new york obviously eric adams won
that's no shock but of course that was a
city that had been moving away from the
radicalism of bill de blasio
in that city's primary elections
so if you look across the country it's
hard to find a bright spot for democrats
and the democrats have so many problems
on their hands
they have infighting inside their party
they have no real direction it's which
way their party wants to go and so the
infighting has already gotten worse like
a lot worse here's the thing
when they don't have trump to unify
their party they got nothing
because this party doesn't know whether
it wants to run down the giant
government path trod by lbj
and joe biden or whether it wants to go
the racial radical route that is pursued
by the squad they really don't know
whether they want to be clintonian or
whether they want to be more along the
lines of obama
barack obama coined a new strategy in
2012 it was mobilize a bunch of
quote-unquote disposed populations
and and aggregate those people together
against the supposedly evil white
majority
that then he won in 2012 and democrats
ever since have been pursuing that model
and in 2020 it worked out for them
because they were running against donald
trump and the media were able to savage
trump and block stories about trump and
trump kept stepping on rakes and so they
were able to win on that model but they
can't win on that model forever
so they have a choice do they go back to
the clintonian third way or do they
continue to prop up the utopian
electoral dreams of barack obama at the
cost of actual power
that is a real battle going on inside
the democratic party right now and it
seems as though the radicals are poised
to win it which is good news for the
republicans if you're a republican you
ought to be real happy with that we'll
get to more of this in just one second
first
you've all heard about policy genius by
now did you know they can also help you
save by bundling your home and auto
insurance as well i mean let's say that
you are about to buy a house and you
think what could happen to this house so
you know you put a down payment on the
house and then an airplane hits the
house
well you you should have thought about
home insurance probably it should have
been like your first move when you
bought the house this is where policy
genius can help policy genius makes it
easy to compare home and auto insurance
in one place they can help you find home
and auto coverage similar to what you
have now but at a lower price they've
saved customers an average of one
thousand two hundred fifty dollars per
year over what they were paying for home
and auto insurance they save new
customers an average of 435 bucks per
year on auto insurance they save new
customers an average of 350 bucks per
year on home insurance and when you
bundle them you save a lot more getting
started is simple first head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro home answer a
few quick questions about yourself and
your property and then policy genius
will take it from there they will
compare the rates from america's top
insurers from progressive to allstate
and find you your lowest quotes head on
over to policygenius.com shapiro home
get started right now policy genius when
it comes to insurance it's nice and
important and responsible to get it
right alrighty so
the democratic party is in real trouble
because they are not sure which way to
turn
and if they listen to msnbc they're
going to turn in the radical direction
so first off let me just say there is
nothing quite as joyous in life as
watching media figures react to
republicans winning races
nothing quite as joyous so last night on
cnn we'll start with cnn last night on
cnn
john king was announcing the results in
virginia to jake tapper and uh jake
tapper is
all the media at large right here this
is this is this reaction is is what the
media thought last night
just about everywhere terry mcauliffe is
underperforming joe biden so you say
okay that's not fair that's a
presidential year is he underperforming
ralph northam i began the night saying
he can ralph northern won by eight nine
points the incumbent democratic
incumbent governor so terry mcauliffe
can underperform him as long as he
doesn't under underperform him by a ton
this is your live vote right now where
are there counties where mcauliffe is
underperforming northern by more than oh
my god by more than 10 points he is
underperforming
[Laughter]
meanwhile larry sabato who had declared
pretty much that everybody who votes in
favor of the republicans is a white
supremacist because they've been taken
in and duped by the evil critical race
theory narrative uh he was like yeah i'm
hearing from the call of campaign it's
just a bloodbath again there's nothing
more fun for republicans than turning on
msnbc on a bad night for democrats
i'm not going to call it a blowout
because we don't have the final
uh final uh numbers but i will tell you
somebody in
high up in
mcauliffe's camp who was there with
mcauliffe
put it this way to me about an hour ago
it's a bloodbath
and so far everything we've seen pretty
much falls along that line and while we
don't have complete figures anything
close to complete figures for the house
of delegates you can guess based on what
i've just said
yeah man so it got it got so good at
msnbc
watching watching msnbc was like
watching several hours of just the last
scene of raiders of the lost ark right
just when they opened the ark and
suddenly
thoughts
face just melts off
right or or when bella just it's just
them screaming as the ark is open just
screaming until their heads explode it's
just the last it's just outtakes from
the last scene of raiders of the lost
ark it's just spectacular so last night
msnbc host remember terry mccullough
lost this race because he decided that a
great campaign strategy was to say that
if you were worried about your child's
education it's because you're a
homophobe or if you're worried about
critical race theory in schools it's
because you're a racist or if you're
against the american federation of
teachers it's because you were some sort
of horrible bigot and school boards
needed to be in charge of your children
not you this was terry mcauliffe's
entire campaign and so the
the idiots over at msnbc
apparently their strategy is to just
keep stripping that chicken they're just
going to keep stopping it
so
so last night msnbc msnbc host decided
it's not us that are wrong it's the
children who are wrong
here they were decrying dangerous racist
republicans now i just want to point
something out
these racist republicans elected last
night a lieutenant governor in virginia
named winsome sears she's a marine
veteran she also happens to be black
okay so they elected a a black woman as
the lieutenant governor because they are
vicious white supremacists they also
elected an attorney general
of virginia who is um a cuban american
to replace a white guy by the way the
current incumbent ag is is a white guy
and they elected glen youngkin to
replace a current democratic incumbent
who was in a yearbook wearing either
blackface or a kkk outfit we still don't
know which
yes it's the republicans who are the
white supremacist clearly here's msnbc
going with that narrative
the question for democrats is going to
be you almost wrong spelled again do you
go on the campaign show with the
republican party you know you've got
that they lie that they wander the trump
racism in
in fleece that they have a propaganda
network that reaches more people than
any candidate's ads for any state
reduction do you adjust with this new
propaganda disinformation fairly veiled
dog whistle race stuff or do you keep
trying to fight on you know policy
oh yeah that cause that was the race the
race was democrats trying to talk policy
and republicans doing veiled dog
whistles
except the critical race theory is
taught in the schools and they tried to
play this gaslighting game for months on
end
you would point out that kids were being
taught racial essentialism in schools
they would be being taught that america
is replete with white privilege that it
is inherent in every major institution
they're being taught 1619 project
garbage in the schools and the entire
take from the democratic party is we're
not even teaching critical race theory
we don't even know what critical race
theory is and then when you say okay
fine so what if we just get rid of it
like no no it's super important that
your kids learn critical race theory
because otherwise they won't be learning
real history
right the gaslighting was very strong
and parents were like you know what you
can just go
yourself like we are not interested in
being told that we are that we are fools
for for wanting to know what our kids
are being taught in school see one of
the things that happened with zoom
school last year is the parents finally
got to see what their kids were being
taught in school and they weren't super
happy about it that is for sure and
meanwhile on msnbc the meltdown
continued steve kornacki trying to
inform the msnbc panel so the people who
hosted this were nicole wallace who's a
hack and joy reid who's the biggest hack
on television and rachel maddow who was
the moderate on the panel
and so steve kornacki trying to deliver
the news
that um democrats were just getting
walloped in virginia and that new jersey
was close
you had to feel a little bit for steve
kornacki because he was basically like
the he's he was sort of like the persian
messenger in 300 who has to deliver the
news to leonidas that the hordes are
coming right
it's just it's gonna go super poorly
right like steve kornacki is like i beg
of you my liege i i it's not me i didn't
vote this way i'm not gonna but i just i
hate to bring you this news like you had
a feel for kornacki right because he's
just he's just trying to bring them the
stats and everybody on msnbc is like
behead him why is gornacky bringing
steve kornack he's like i'm just the
messenger guys like yes well here we
shoot the messenger okay so you can see
kornacki's expression he's like oh god
this job ah some nights hey so here's
rachel maddow complaining that um fox
kept talking about critical race theory
how could they talk about critical race
theory it's not like it was a major
issue for people what their kids were
being taught in schools
here's rachel maddow doing this routine
to have the fox news channel our friends
at the fox news channel
building their programming particularly
the prime time programming around this
four months they're building a campaign
platform for conservative candidates to
run on it everywhere even
though it's not actually anywhere even
though it's not a real thing i mean that
there's there's nothing you could pay
for in any campaign that would equal the
kind of free help you'd get from that
sort of conservative media just fire
hose on the issue
okay i love that i i you gotta love the
lack of awareness from rachel maddow i
mean there's nothing like like free
media coverage of an issue that
republicans care about yes rachel i'm
sure that's what happened in virginia
what happened in virginia for sure is
that republican media are just so
dominant they're just so powerful all
the time republican media i mean what
it's not like there's a network
that spends all day every day pushing a
democratic agenda it's not like every
host on a network pushes that agenda in
the most radical possible do you own a
mirror people you're on msnbc
and you're saying oh man look at those
republicans fire hosing republican
issues i mean just just terrible look at
fox and and all these conservative media
okay i'm just gonna name a few networks
just off the top of my head here msnbc
cnn abc
cbs nbc
the new york times the washington post
right now we're not getting that's now
our newspapers new york times washington
post l.a times chicago tribune
every major outlet
every major outlet with the exception of
essentially the wall street journal and
fox news
every legacy media outlet supports the
democrats and they're like i can't
believe this fox news these fox news
people did ever occur to them that maybe
the reason people watch fox news is
because you guys won't report
again i refer you over to daily wire get
a subscription because luke rosiak did
the reporting these jokers wouldn't do
our investigative journalist lugrozak
did a yeoman's work in loudoun county
and you should support that work because
your entire journalism population won't
do any of that work instead they will
just repeat that remember the entire
luke rosiac story about scott smith who
is the parent who was wrestled to the
ground and called the domestic terrorist
because he was angry that the school
board had said that no one had been
raped in a bathroom and he knew that his
daughter had
remember the entire media just ran with
the story that he was a domestic
terrorist it took lou grossiac to
uncover the fact that he was actually
just a rightly pissed off parent
hey but and this is the theme over at
msnbc just keep stuck in that chicken
man stop it until it's not frozen
anymore here's see here is nicole
wallace again saying critical race
theory is fake it's all fake it's all in
your imagination
what is happening in sort of republican
america it's not just critical race
theory it's it's saying you know fraud
happened their people believe there was
fraud so they're fixing it so republican
voters think republicans never mind that
it's fake that's critical race theory
isn't taught it means something
different to voters they think it is so
republicans are fixing it junk is going
to ban it and some of it is just a
question for democrats now do you adjust
to a terrain that is not fair that is
not just that it's all fact-based but
that this tonight looks like it
advantages republica
it's unreal it's unreal they're just
gonna keep denying it they're just gonna
keep denying and then they'll tell you
it's super important to follow it
now here's joy reid who's the worst of
the bunch over there joy reid is just
the fact that she's on a nightly show is
such an unbelievable joke because i'm
not sure that she said a correct thing
in several years at this point
so she says that when you say education
in virginia what you really mean
is white parents don't like teaching
about race
when white people say education what
they really mean is white supremacy
keep on going with this really like i'm
just gonna i'm just gonna sit back here
you guys do your thing in fact
i would love to nominate if i had the
power i would nominate joy reid to be
head of the dnc she should be they
should just follow her strategy just
keep calling everything you don't like
white supremacy see how that works out
for you here is joy reid
and the exit poll showed that
which was interesting that the
coronavirus or that the virus it was a
very low importance to many voters it
was education right which is code for
white parents don't like the idea of
teaching about race and i mean
unfortunately
race is just the most palpable tool in
the tool kit used to be of the
democratic party back in the day when
there were dixiecrats and now of the
republican party it just is powerful
okay it was glenn it was it was glenn
young being attacked by tara mcauliffe
as a racist
it was it was mcauliffe making race the
issue it was that old white guy telling
you that all the republicans were racist
that was the campaign
republicans were just saying we don't
want our kids taught that some people
are worse because of their race and it
was democrats saying if you don't teach
that you won't teach history and you're
a racist
joy reid accusing others of playing the
race card
i mean honest to god it's like o.j
simpson accusing you of murder like
that's not
there's something wrong here
joy reid has several decks of cards
except it's like a magic deck the only
card in the deck is the race car that is
the only card in all of her myriad decks
there are no kings there are no tens
there are no eights it's just the race
card that's all and she does it every
night on her show for every issue and
then she's like these republicans
they're constantly playing the race card
can you believe it can you
and then you wonder why we went crazy
and then you wonder why everybody went
out and voted against the democrats keep
on going guys keep on going
cnn's van jones did some of the same
stuff he was saying well you know glenn
junkin he's just the delta variant trump
delta variant trump because you see
trump is like a disease and glen
youngkin is like a worse more virulent
form of the disease this is not going to
work because glenn young can number one
is not trump and number two people do
not see basic conservatism as a disease
here's van jones when this election is
over in virginia we will know
have we seen the emergence of the delta
variant of trumpism
the delta variant of trumpism in other
words junkin uh same disease but spreads
a lot faster it can get a lot more
places the suburbs if they fall to him
you know that's implying that yeah that
junkin is more dangerous than what is it
well
no no more easy to spread okay because
more easier to spread because if you if
you look at what he's doing he is
playing footsie with the worst of trump
isn't
is he really
come on get washably summed up this
entire line of attack in a tweet last
night former cnn commentator whiteness
remains undefeated let's wait and see
who these white suburban voters went for
tonight in virginia any guesses
whiteness remains undefeated again first
black female lieutenant governor in
virginia first hispanic a.g in virginia
whiteness remains undefeated weird
because uh nine months ago
joe biden won that state by 10 points
nine months ago
so
yeah man whiteness remains undefeated
that's a solitaire keep going with that
really just keep going
i'm i'm just gonna really please please
all right in one second we'll get to
more on this because the democrats have
a couple of paths they're going to take
and i'm really hoping that they continue
to double down on the stupid first let
us talk about the fact that a lot of
people suffer from nausea right you
might get car sickness my wife tends to
get car sick you might get anxiety
migraines hangovers morning sickness a
lot of reasons people get nauseous but
there's a great easy solution i'm
talking about relief band it's the
number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband it's been clinically proven to
quickly relieve and effectively prevent
nausea and vomiting the product is 100
drug-free non-drowsy provides
all-natural long-lasting relief with
zero side effects for as long as needed
the technology was originally developed
over 20 years ago in hospitals to
relieve nausea from patients but now
through a relief band it's available to
the masses relief band stimulates the
nerve in the wrist it travels to the
part of the brain that controls nausea
then it blocks the signal your brain is
sending to your stomach telling you
you're sick relief band just released
its newest model relief band sport the
sport is waterproof it features
interchangeable bands and it has
extended battery life my wife uses
relief and when we're in the car it
really works for her my sister also uses
relief and i got her one as well as the
holiday season quickly approaches
there's never been a better time to give
the gift of relief make sure your loved
ones are nausea free right now relief
ban has an exclusive offer just for my
listeners if you go to reliefband.com
and use promo code shapiro you'll
receive 20 off plus free shipping no
questions asked 30 day money back
guarantee head on over to relief band
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a
use our promo code shapiro for 20 off
plus free shipping alrighty we'll get to
more on the democrats in just one moment
because they are indeed falling apart
first
if you've been searching for a daily
morning podcast without an agenda look
no further than the morning wire
remember that loud and county story i
was talking about luke rosiak
morningware was all over that one
they're giving you the news you need to
know without the left-wing spin and they
do it in 15 minutes or less while we're
working overtime to bring you the news
you do need to know we need your help to
keep the facts trending toward number
one subscribe start listening right now
to morning wire on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts leave a
five star review if you like what you
hear and i will remind you again that if
you want to support investigative
journalism like the journalism luke
rosiak did in loudoun county that makes
a big difference in how people think and
how people understand the world you need
to support us by subscribing we need
your support because investigative
journalism is super expensive we need
more reporters like luke so go subscribe
use promo code real news for 25 off
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so now that democrats have a
real problem on their hands which
direction do they move do they move in
the direction of the moderate who's like
joe biden
or do they move in the direction of the
squad
now here's the thing joe biden is not
moderate and this is the problem with
running as a moderate and then not
governing as a moderate it means that
even if you're trying to look moderate
you seem as though you're far left
because in fact you are as chris wallace
pointed out in fox news last night terry
mcauliffe was dragged down by biden he
was not helped by biden who's dragged
down by biden
it's really interesting there have been
some white house operatives who've been
putting out the word all day this is not
a referendum on joe biden which is an
odd thing to do when your guy terry
mcauliffe has a chance of winning it
almost seems like they have been
pre-bottling pre-budding the idea that
don't blame us if mcauliffe loses but
there's no question that that uh
joe biden has had an impact on this race
his sharp decline in the polls he's
about 42 43 support in virginia if he
were at 52 or 53 i think that mcauliffe
would have a much better chance of
winning tonight so mcauliffe instead of
having an asset in joe biden and his
agenda has i think kind of had to
carry him like a wave tied to his ankle
hey according to jonathan martyr martin
over at the new york times even before
the polls closed a biden advisor
recoiled at the democratic governor's
talking points noting biden swoon in the
polls
they say it's not biden it's just the
term mccall have muffed it
okay except it's both right it's the
terry mcauliffe did a horrible job in
the campaign and also that joe biden
supports all that stuff okay there is no
daylight between joe biden and terry
mcauliffe they campaigned it together
joe biden endorses the message of terry
mcauliffe on education they are on the
same page mcauliffe was a so-called
moderate so where did democrats move
joe biden is falling apart the
democratic party can either follow him
and fall apart or they cannot follow him
and fall apart these are their two
choices right now
and again joe biden is doing a terrible
job so biden yesterday whose question
about inflation in glasgow it went very
very poorly for him because inflation
continues to dog american families and
meanwhile this dummy is trying to is
trying to infuse several trillion more
dollars into the economy the definition
of inflation is more dollars less
product
okay and he's and his solution that is
more dollars less product sounds great
here's more cowbell joe biden
it doesn't mean these dislocations
aren't real they do affect people's
lives for example one of the reasons why
i decided to talk about the need to deal
with
the the operation and the gouging that
occurs in some of the
pricing of beef and chicken and other
things is that uh that's why i think
we're i think that's why i indicated you
we're going to look at whether or not
there's a violation of of antitrust laws
and what they're doing
good luck with this guy good luck with
this guy
james carville
who again is actually pretty good at his
job he's been warning democrats you guys
are getting too radical he's like we
suck at talking about the economy yes
yes you do
i don't think the democrats have done
near a good enough job of talking about
how really good
this economy is for workers i mean you
look at the quit rate
i mean it's stagnantly good and workers
have more power now than they had at any
time in this century and i i do think
that our communications i think the
white house communication has been bad
i'm very critical of people like myself
that have access
to shows like you that i haven't framed
this work well and i blame cnn and new
york times and everybody else
yeah he blames everybody for the fact
that biden is bad at his job and here's
the thing if you're gonna follow the
moderates the moderates are with biden
on his spending plans okay literally the
only two people who the democrats have
decided are verboten at this point are
mansion and cinema now let's say that
you're kristen mann kirsten cinema from
arizona or joe manchin from west
virginia so you're in arizona a very
purple state and you just watched a blue
state turn entirely red
or let's say that you're joe manchin and
you're in the reddest state in america i
have a question what exactly is your
impetus to now vote for bill back better
why would you do anything joe biden
wants you to do instead you are much
safer not doing anything they want you
to do and then running and maybe winning
or you can vote for everything joe biden
wants and you can go down in flaming
defeat in your home state but the only
two democrats the democrats will not
follow at this point are mentioned in
cinema instead of taking their foot off
the gas and pumping the break a little
bit instead they're like yeah mansion
and cinema no so the choice now is
between two losers joe biden and the
squad those are the choices inside the
democratic party
and it's not going particularly well
it's not going great so on the one side
you have the joe biden team saying we
need to spend more money if only we had
spent more money we wouldn't won this
election if only we had passed bill back
better we would have won in virginia
there is no evidence for this
none okay no evidence that bill back
better would have fixed anything for
democrats in virginia or new jersey or
pennsylvania or long island or
minneapolis or buffalo right no evidence
that it would have fixed anything for
the for the democrats in any of these
areas
okay but
that's what that's biden's case give me
more power to spend more money and
everything will be great it's not true
and then you have the squad and the
squad are like
or you could do this spend even more
money and also call americans deeply
racist at every available turn and talk
about equity and how america's
institutions are completely corrupt if
these are your two bifurcating paths is
the democratic party you got a lot of
problems so again james carville on the
one end saying let's spend more money
and then you have joy rita on the other
end saying the future of the party is to
spend even more money than the democrats
typically want to do and to racially
pander in the process
it's the idea that the buildback better
bill which has got all the stuff for
women and people of color
it's got all this stuff for environment
for young people that that bill is seen
as secondary to democrats in washington
and all they care about is the bill that
in their mind will win them back like
you know white independent voters
do you think that democrats can take
that lesson out of this or do you think
that they're just going to take the
usual lesson and you know as julian
castro just said go find another
centrist and try the same game again
next time
it's amazing it's amazing so the center
so the centrist argument at this point
is what if we spend slightly less money
than god has ever seen and the
non-centrist argument is what if we
spend slightly more money than god has
ever seen
and these are this is the battle inside
the democratic party
man things are getting ugly and they're
gonna get there it's gonna be you know
retirements are coming for the democrats
if you are a house democrat in a purple
district do you really want to run for
reelection in this environment with this
leadership team with this media
environment is this really what you want
you should think pretty seriously about
it it ain't stopping joe biden because
biden
biden you know normally you say that
when somebody's playing chicken they put
a brick on the accelerator the thing
about joe biden is he is the brick on
the accelerator he's an inanimate object
who's been placed on the accelerator and
he's just going to lie there and what
this means is that he has to keep
doubling down so build back better is
the plan and they're going to keep
pushing bill back better so joe biden
yesterday he's out there making the case
for bill back better and just lying to
you he's saying that his spending plan
is going to lower inflation
they just got blown out in virginia
blown out
and they nearly lost new jersey like
it's still a squeaker it's gonna go to
recount and joe biden's like yeah the
best thing we can do right now is just
force through a big spending bill that
nobody seems to like very much and it'll
lower inflation
17 nobel laureates and economics said
it's going to lower inflation
raise wages increase competition
create
2 million jobs a year etc and so i think
that
i understand that joe was looking
for the precise detail to make sure
nothing got
slipped in in terms of the way in which
the legislation got written that is
different than he
acknowledged he would agree to
yeah good luck with this meanwhile chuck
schumer is still trotting out the lie
that this entire planet is going to be
paid for because he might he has to push
it right they just have to they don't
have a choice rick on the accelerator
here we go
it doesn't do everything i would want or
many of us would want but it takes a big
step forward
all the while buildback better will be
fully paid for and will ultimately
relieve our nation's inflationary
pressures
no one believes this no one believes
this okay and meanwhile what are the
democrats actually doing this is the
part that's the best
so the new democratic plan has in it a
salt deduction they're putting back the
salt deduction so all these all these
tax the rich eat the rich folks they're
actually creating a carve out for rich
democrats in blue areas according to the
new york times democrats were readying
an agreement on tuesday that would
repeal a cap on the amount of state and
local taxes homeowners can deduct as
part of a broader 1.85 trillion spending
bill a move that could amount to a
significant tax cut for wealthy
americans in liberal states but some
liberals quickly balked at the emerging
agreement which would suspend a ten
thousand dollar cap on the so-called
salt deduction for five years removing
limit republicans included in their 2017
tax package as a way to pay for cuts for
corporations and the rich i love how the
new york times poses this that the the
assault deduction elimination was
designed as a way to pay for tax cuts
for rich people no the salt deduction
elimination hit rich people
okay because the salt deduction
elimination basically said that if you
live in a blue state you can take your
taxes for your state taxes and then
deduct the state taxes against your
federal taxes it really helped rich
people in blue states didn't help rich
people in florida or texas where there's
no state income tax it helped rich
people in california this is what
democrats are pushing democrats want
that salt deduction republicans remove
the assault deduction because they said
why exactly should voters in florida or
texas who have zero state income tax be
subsidizing the state income tax of
places like new york and california now
democrats want to put that back in it's
pretty regressive here's larry summers
from her treasury secretary under bill
clinton saying uh yeah you guys who say
that you want to fight the rich why are
you giving the rich giveaways
in the way this bill is likely to pass
it's not completely clear yet depending
on what happens to state and local
taxation
there will be a large number of people
with incomes of say eight or nine
million dollars who are going to see
their taxes uh go down and i'm not sure
that this was a time when
people in the top tenth of a percent of
the income distribution top hundredth of
a percent of the income distribution
should be getting a tax cuts
the infighting is going to get much
worse bernie sanders said yesterday i
think there's a compromise to be reached
here a middle ground which says that for
families earning less than 400 000 they
can take a complete exemption but not
families anymore on that what exists is
unacceptable and one way or not it will
be dealt with just keep going to war
with each other keep going war meanwhile
mitch mcconnell doing the easy thing
he's saying listen
nobody wants this bill nobody's calling
for bill back better you guys think that
if you ram this through it's going to
save you right now this is an unpopular
bill it is now the only question is why
do they even get the infrastructure bill
the reason being
right now there's enough republican
support for the infrastructure bill to
get it over the top in the senate right
you got mitt romney got susan collins
got a bunch of other republicans on
board with the infrastructure bill in
the senate when it goes to the house
it's unclear how many house republicans
are actually going to vote for
infrastructure and democrats right now
do not have enough progressives on board
to simply pass the infrastructure bill
because the progressives have been
saying we need some sort of commitment
from joe manchin and kirsten cinema to
vote for bill back better but now
manchester united ain't voting for bill
back better why would they
after the ju absolute drubbing that
democrats took in virginia again if you
are a purple state democrat or a red
state democrat you can't look at that
and think to yourself man i really need
to move along with a big spending agenda
most americans are not on board with and
here's mitch mcconnell pointing out the
obvious when it comes to bill back
better
this is a bill america does not want and
does not need
the ideal solution would be
to not pass it
but
if it's surpassed it'll be written by
mansion and or cinema
okay and um he's right about that but
here's the thing
right now
i don't think bill back better gets done
maybe at all maybe at all if it does
it's going to get scaled way down even
from where it is right now mansion and
cinema have no interest in passing this
thing it cuts directly against their
political interests and if manchester
united don't vote for that are the
progressives going to vote for
infrastructure
and what are they going to do
because if there are enough progressives
who don't vote for infrastructure and
that that's the radicals that's corey
bush and aoc and and all the rest of the
the progressive democrats who really
have nothing to lose here right if they
vote down infrastructure to protest
mansion and cinema the voters aren't
going to punish them for that they're
going to reward them for that so now the
question becomes if you're a house
republican do you hand biden an
infrastructure bipartisan bill victory
or do you simply vote it down and say
you guys had a majority in the house you
democrats we're not going to help you if
you decide to vote down your own bill
that's your problem you guys can't get
it together enjoy the
enjoy the french fries
because really that's this is on you
and remember it's going to get worse for
democrats because democrats pushed off
the debt ceiling until the beginning of
december
and it was mitch mcconnell who said okay
well this is the last time we'll push
off the debt ceiling until december
we're not helping you at that point so
if you want the debt ceiling raised at
that point you're going to have to do so
through the reconciliation process which
has all sorts of effects on how
democrats vote
because in order to do it via
reconciliation you have to have
essentially what's called the voter rama
where everybody votes up or down on a
bunch of popular or unpopular proposals
democrats have been desperately
attempting to avoid this this is why
they wanted a large consensus to push
off the debt ceiling so if you're a
democrat right now
you have so many conflicts on your hands
makes your head swim you got joe biden
deeply unpopular president dragging you
down because he is literally a human
anchor
he is just an a not animate object that
is dragging you to the bottom of the
political sea
you got that problem then you got the
split between joe manchin and kristen
cinnamon the rest of the party and
instead of you following the irrational
people in your party like mansion and
cinema you've decided they're bad so
you have to ignore them they're they're
bad they're bad okay meanwhile you have
the battle between the so-called
moderate wing which is like biden who is
not moderate and the squad
and that battle is breaking out into the
open
and then meanwhile you have the debt
ceiling coming up in early december you
have no infrastructure bill that has
passed you have a build back better plan
that has no support from mansion and
cinema at this point
the problems are only going to multiply
in the near future they are not getting
better for democrats anytime in the near
future and they don't have trump to kick
around this is the best thing right
because trump was the unifying factor in
the democratic parties they're just
going to keep screaming january 6 but
guess what it didn't work in virginia it
didn't work in new jersey no one cares
january 6 happened nearly a year ago at
this point americans are not waiting
around on the latest wapo investigation
about who is saying what in the middle
of the january sixth riot
i mean nobody is
as long as that is not the key issue
democrats are in a world of hurt and the
senate map in 2022 looks increasingly
grim for them
right now it looks very much like maggie
hassan in new hampshire is set to go
down
it looks very much like republicans in
pennsylvania may have a shot
particularly if conor lamb is not
nominated for the democratic party
it looks as though the senate seat in
wisconsin it looked as though it's
trending blue may be trending red again
if you are a senator in georgia a
democratic senator in georgia right now
you got to be running scared
democrats
2022 is coming for you
it's coming for you and this is a
disaster of your own making you had one
job don't be crazy and you blew it and
this is the after effect feel the wrath
of the american voters alrighty we'll be
back here later today with an additional
hour of content in the meantime go check
out the michael mills show today he
discusses more on a glorious day for
republicans in virginia you can hear
more details about that over on
michael's show that's available right
now i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pawel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica crans the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
glenn younkin the republican candidate
wins the governorship in virginia
ron desantis rightly bullies woke
businesses and amy barrett blows it on
an important supreme court case check it
out on the michael knowles
[Music]
show you